husband
[Music]
do it bro
he can't even kiss his man right now
like that's crazy dude
let's go do it again don't make it too
dramatic no kisses Little Monkeys
[Music]
okay let's just restart and then you
guys just both go slow it's over right
here okay ready you may now kiss the
husband
[Music]
buddy welcome to flagrant um listen a
lot of people are making a very big deal
about this the fact that that Jonah and
Lauren didn't kiss in a movie
the movie's fake wait they didn't get
married Bro they didn't get married
Eddie Murphy's not a Nation of Islam
okay Julia Louis dreyf is not Jewish you
didn't storm the key might be Jewish I
didn't stop the capital oh yeah I guess
you didn't okay certainly we had a
podcast that day yeah no we were busy my
point is there's these people that are
getting like so upset that I exposed
that a movie was for Avatar is not real
I hate to break it to you Avatar is not
a real [__] movie what I'm confused
about is why people at home are like
nothing better kiss yeah and it's like
while to respect shorty and her
decisions if she doesn't want to or
respect Jonah in his decision maybe she
feels uncomfortable doing in front of
that many people there's hundreds of
people in the room because it's a
[__] wedding scene why don't you let
the girl do what she wants with her body
or let the dude do what he wants in his
body where is this this audience out of
nowhere that's like no that for me to
believe the plot they better they better
make out yeah who [__] are you watch the
free movie on Netflix that you steal the
password from your ex-wife
do you know what I mean that you're
still allowed to do shout out to Netflix
all I'm trying to say it's a movie bro I
guess people are curious they're like oh
why would you bring it up because I
thought that [__] was hilarious because
I saw it happen
I saw him not kiss right and I was like
how are you gonna play this in the movie
and then when I watch it for the first
time with Dove I noticed the CGI right
and I was like oh that's how they played
it so you didn't think it was not fair
that they should over there they
shouldn't have used that was funny yo if
a woman doesn't want to kiss somebody in
a [__] movie
they don't have to and if a man doesn't
want to kiss a girl in a movie they
don't have to right this idea that the
audience is going to demand it you're
like a little bit crazy yeah like if
you're upset about that you're a little
crazy creepy it's creepy those are the
same people that's gonna that's gonna
say oh we shouldn't pressure these
people into doing certain things well
why are you pressured I just think it
hits so many millions of people it was
like the biggest movie on Netflix in the
pack [__] however many months yeah
and so millions of people saw it and
then there's obviously detractors that
didn't like it for whatever reason the
political thing that oh there's a racial
Dynamic and this is stupid whatever
whatever so now they're finding anything
that they can to try to attach their
narrative to why they don't like it yeah
there are people that are upset and
they're looking for justification but
like yo telling a woman what to do with
her body is not the justification you
want to die on that's not the cross you
want to die at least I'm only giving you
advice out here it's like I'm not gonna
be the one going if a woman signs up for
a movie those lips are mine
you know what I'm saying like that's a
little bit crazy yeah yeah you're being
a little crazy to me seeing how it
actually happened I was like oh okay
you know it's crazy though he ended up
having a pretty big role in the movie
when you think about it yeah he had a
huge role he's not on screen and
promoting it
yeah promoting it that's what I'm saying
I need to charge more listen when you
get when I'm in a movie that's like you
just you're mad now because you didn't
know that there was an option to not do
that you did a gazing you had to
actually do it yeah that's true I didn't
know I didn't know I could say no I
didn't know I had that power I wanted to
make it in Hollywood yeah they said you
know what I mean your character's gay
we'll use it I put my hands on the tile
I put my hands on the tile I said just
make sure you don't have it in the shot
my face squinting but don't show
anything else yeah I didn't know what I
could do it was a different time they
had a key grip behind him that's a
different time yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
all I'm trying to say is a thing that
happened in the movie that doesn't
expose anything about the movie and has
brought in millions of people like has
opened the eyes of millions of people
about it and wanted them to see it
that's a net positive also makes the
people who made the movie look cool
because they respect the demands of the
actors how many creepy [__] producers
and directors you hear about in
Hollywood making people do uncomfortable
[__] literally the whole me too movement
is producers and directors are making
women do things that they don't feel
comfortable in movies right the whole
new two movie started about it now we
have a perfect situation where you have
the producers and directors that are
acquiescing to the demands of the actors
saying they don't feel comfortable doing
something and that's a negative nice I
need to see the names that people are
upset about this that's progress low-key
I need to see the names of the people
I've said about this I think we need to
have a conversation with them about
about how they want to control what
women do with their bodies
you know I really gotta say to everybody
involved in the movie
what's that you're welcome
for showcasing how kind and
understanding you are of your actors I
mean considerate and making sure that
they feel comfortable in the roles that
you have given them yeah that is
you got another movie coming out did
anything not happen in that one
cares did it
movie [__] gonna see
[__] gonna see it there listen
for how how long I'm in the movie The
amount of influence in terms of how many
people saw it has never happened before
in a film
this never happened before in the film
it's been a movie where there were some
titties that you went to go see just for
the titties right back in the day yes
every movie Wild Things Wild Things yeah
so wild things wow those titties
probably had a better Roi
your boy is not a star well the titties
aren't the movie the titties are a cameo
say what the titties were a camera
titties I mean they were kids
threesome the titties were so crazy that
Nev Campbell who was the other girl in
the threesome didn't even take her shirt
off wow because it was like what's the
point I can't we're not looking anyway
that's it our eyes are averted as simple
as that
let's do it with this one hey bro it was
and my boy Matt Dillon come on come on I
mean just truly unreal oh [__] that's
part of the scene yeah hey
she's gorgeous yeah that was a crazy
that was a crazy moment
yeah yeah we might have to run this back
I mean she got the one-piece bathing
suit on that was good damn yo Matt
Dillon is really champagne poppy if we
want to keep it oh [__] no disrespect to
Drake but champagne poppy is Matt Dillon
Wild Thing yeah bro you did it first you
saw us in the theater son say what you
saw this enemy I saw in the theater I
saw it at home
I saw it at home the bathroom like I
been seeing this movie in so many
different places
bro
what you got dust you got the
screenshots on your phone no he got
it yeah we maybe should put that [__] on
we should put this please
edit it we'll edit it so this is culture
why are they yeah what do they want you
to do they want you to unsay it this is
culture okay listen yeah yeah yeah yeah
and make sure you end it with you're
welcome yeah millions
millions yeah you welcome Millions bro